La chérie de La Havane, moi et moi, détestons
laisser ça sur votre téléphone, mais ils ont
annoncé que Damien était parti avec un Zeta que je
connais et je respecte les raisons pour lesquelles
c'était si important de se produire dans la
famille en visite lors de la dernière saison de
louanges de Lord Zoe faisant 300 000 semaines
ça fait neuf ans qu'est-ce qu'ils
offrent cinq millions que pensez-vous que
je pense que nous avons leurs couilles vanakkam sur
l'acheminement de l'achat de celui-ci elle avait l'habitude de
laisser les producteurs lui mettre leurs [ __ ] dans le
cul et p nous avons embauché une fille c'est incroyable
pourquoi est-ce incroyable  ce n'est pas un
chow très glamour Je n'ai pas l'habitude du glamour
qu'elle a défiguré gagné dans un incendie
les gens nerveux n'entrent pas dans sa
vie au hasard nous avons appelé ce
qu'elle fait ici peut-être qu'elle a dit en voyant si
cavalière je ne peux pas croire  je viens de dépenser
dix-huit mille dollars allons-y le
van de la soeur Rose Je suis un grand fan Oh
Gaston les gens m'ont appelé trois fois oh
mon dieu azita eh bien est-il juste à l'
hôpital tu sais qu'elle l'a totalement perdu non
je sais que c'est au-delà mais toi  Je veux toujours le
faire
na Nana na na hé hé hé au revoir
allez chante-le sur le front de mes amis
à chaque main tendue j'écris ton nom à
propos de ta sœur je pense qu'elle est peut-être de
retour pense que tu es un peu
fou  je suis plus belle qu'elle tu veux
ce rôle mais tu n'obtiendras pas ce
que c'était comme un rêve mais ça a l'air
tellement réel je suis vivant et je ne suis pas fou
tu ne peux pas avoir cru que je
te laisserais venir  reviens et baise encore mon
monde sur les marches de la mort j'écris
ton nom Liberty
toi